why do you get to make movies because I
would love to be a musician but I suck
at it
but I love music and sometimes music is
more interesting them that's why I
combine a lot of music in my film but I
don't know I love just it's not really
this the story that I love to make it's
more the process and the end result I
love creating just beautiful scene just
preparing the scene kind of sad but when
you see the visual when you are on set
and you see all the the possibility
that's happening you see the beauty
happening and then you go to the editing
room and you put the music on and there
there's just something so realistic
happening and that's that's why I think
I love to create so those surrealist ik
vision that I have because I'm not a big
fan of just real a real film like in a
way that it's pure real life and I love
to create something that visually looks
dreamy and that that's what kind of
turned me on so if I cannot have because
I love those vibe in music so I think
just combining the two is the perfect
media to do that I'm a very visual
person and plus music and it just helps
me to create those visions something
that I have why do you get to do it I
guess it's just I don't want to say a
calling but it's it's true it's just
it's just naturally he just had happened
the first time when I was like 17
I used the camera it was just like whoa
there's something it's just you just
like you fall in love you know I mean
it's just something that you can not
control that it's just so strong that
you have to do it and it was the same
thing so as soon as I started playing
with that was just like just make sense
I don't care about the rest just I have
to create something you know there's a
lot of people that see films and
sometimes their criticism comes from the
fact that they wish they could do it and
they can't for whatever reason so if
someone were to say well what makes you
able to do it and you felt that from
them
what would you tell them because it's
more than just being able to just like
you know have these beautiful images you
show up you have a plan in place you had
your whole online sort of present so
that this investor or investors see it
we're ready but some people don't see
all that behind the scenes work and they
get maybe envious or they get critical
when they shouldn't but that's what I
think makes the difference between the
one who's gonna make it and the one who
doesn't you know you can dream about it
but at one point you have to stop and go
do it
and if you don't then continue dreaming
about it but you have to start somewhere
and even for me when I started I was so
afraid to do anything I was like oh it's
gonna look crappy and it was horrible
no more but the more you do you get
better you start to learn the business
you start to learn how to make something
great and that's that's exciting
to know that you are evolving and you're
getting better and better and better and
then you see some kind of reaction from
the audience and that's amazing what you
did and when you look back now it's
horrible and I'm sure when I'm gonna
look back 20 years from now my first
feature film I'm gonna set my god what
I've done but for now is I think it's
amazing so it's a long process and
sometime people doesn't want to take the
adventure it can be like a 15 20 30
years adventure and people just want to
see result now and it's not that it
doesn't work like that
even if all the technology is available
now there's no excuse at this point now
the anybody can take a camera and go
shoot and even if it's horrible at least
you did something you're gonna be proud
of it and fail would it be proud of it
you know what I mean so that's I don't
know that's that's where the passion
comes through if you just want to do
that for money reason or something like
that it's it's never gonna work
we talked about earlier being impatient
and I get that I think a lot of artists
are you know they kind of want what they
want now right but you're willing to be
patient to build a body of work what do
you think the change is
like why there yeah you're willing to be
you know that this is not going to be
just one film you know that then they'll
be I'm sure know exactly UF that that's
like again is it comes back from the
first thing you need to love it and if
you know that you love it and you really
want to do that and you really want to
put the passion and devotion and
dedication into it you know it's it's an
automatic that you understand that it's
gonna take a long time and you cannot
keep it you know that's why I know that
I'm not gonna go ask for a film of two
million dollar right away I'm not there
yet so I want to get better and I want
to get better at writing I want to get
better at chemical work or whatever what
you know I want to get better and when I
feel that I'm at that stage I'll do
whatever it takes to go there so yeah
you have to be patient
totally I've heard from other people
that are not in LA or New York that
there's a lot of artists other places
and and I know we're in a sort of a
global village now where anybody can
make things and put them out and have
them seen but I think sometimes people
say that others in other parts of the
world or state sometimes they make
excuses for not doing certain things so
what are those excuses that you hear
from others and how do you combat that
in yourself for not making something
again for me it's all about I'm gonna
say that a lot but it's all about
passion you know if you for you you have
excuses right away and when you're
starting quit right away it's not gonna
be for you and and now it's so easy with
Vimeo YouTube Facebook whatever it's
just you take your work if you just know
what to do a little bit people will see
it just for me after all what ten years
people like around two million people
saw my work and from so that's great it
takes a lot of time you know that if
there's no excuse that's a thing now you
just show it on Vimeo and people will
just comment right away and I think it's
just a fear of putting the work in
because people have day job oh it's
gonna cost money but or it's sometime
they don't have the skill to do that so
they are super afraid to try something
or I can not find someone who's just try
everybody got a camera now people shoot
with high phones you know I mean it's
like there's no excuse not to at least
try experiment for yourself
put put something online see
reaction people will give you tips
people will just comment people will say
I'm a fan now or whatever but again it
just there's two lines you're doing it
or you finally kind of stupid excuse not
to do so
I don't know I don't drive like that
it's I think it's just it's a
little bit that it's just you know I
mean it's just for me doesn't make sense
if that's it do you think it's laziness
or fear that's what you said it's both I
think first it's laziness I think
because it's like ah have to write
something have to write five pages 5:15
write that in ten minutes who cares even
if it's horrible write something and
then then I'll have to find a camera I
have to find a sound guy just when you
start thinking about all those stages
that's where I think people just like
I'll do it the main tomorrow or I'll do
it in whatever army man I mean yeah I
know a friend who there's always gonna
be excuses like that so and sometime
people doesn't have the confidence that
it can do it themselves and that's what
I've learned for myself is I just go and
see what works for you I know I suck at
sound I know that so that's why when I
work I want to make sure that I have a
great sound guy I know I do I do great
images so I'm gonna focus on that and so
you just need to know but for that to
understand that - exactly click with
your strengths and weaknesses you need
to try and so if you really want to do
that laziness or fear should not be
their fear that's fine you can always
beat that laziness you cannot I think
because I think when you're lazy is
because you're not passionate about it
so how many short films have you done
before on the horizon a feature total I
think like 30 30
Wow yeah I think online you can only see
like 10 because I blocked them all
because I don't want people to see my
early work and but that's fine it's
sometimes just for me I love doing the
the whole point about short films or
music videos is to find your signature
is to find your your voice as a director
and even actors you know you need to do
so to really find your niche so but
director I think it's so crucial to have
your signature otherwise I don't know
it's from its
if you want people to really know oh
that's the thing by Pascal you need to
work to indentify that style like first
of all David Lynch as soon as you press
play you know exactly it's a David Lynch
film so I want a same thing from you I
want to say oh that's that's a thing for
Pascal but for that it takes time to
really find that voice and once you do
then people can connect with you and
then I think it makes you more unique to
get maybe investors because they can see
that unique voice because if you just do
something generic or you're kind of a
generic director with just yeah it's a
great but who directed it and I know
exactly because there's nothing special
about it yeah the great acting rate this
but there's not a style but doesn't
personally I'm not a big fan of just
generic director I love when it's let's
say you know David Lynch peaky Anderson
it's those directors that is just like
you know exactly it's a fan by them
that's what makes them special I think
so over 30 films you've been able to
definitely see then what you're good at
and then in terms of like you said you
weren't good at sound so hiring a sound
guy so you feel if that's been the
weeding out process and also the honing
process for you to know what your
specialty is yeah and at the same time
you cannot do everything even if you
want to you cannot do everything you can
not shoot and at the same time I've
great sound you know there's the limits
that you can do but I've I feel that if
you know at least your weaknesses and
your strengths you can really go on and
make the best with what you have and
that can that's where you save money
because if you start I need like 25
people they're a big crew that that does
that's where cost money unless you have
25 friends who's willing to work for
free but for me for my film I always pay
my people you know yeah maybe there's
not a lot of people but at least I make
sure that they're getting paid
you